[Musik]
wir haben jetzt luca und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen blog
aus paris wurde da man hier nicht die
gerade auf dem bett guten morgen auf ein
jude hier das hier ist unser letzter tag
in paris wir waren jetzt vier tage hier
und unser zug fährt heute um 18 uhr
das heißt wir haben noch sieben stunden
um irgendetwas zu unternehmen wie ich
sitze gerade auf toilette weltfrieden
wir haben die letzten tage schon relativ
viel erlebt also jahren schon beim
louvre zum beispiel
super gutes foto luca und wer mal
immerhin schon relativ viel von paris
gesehen als wären eigentlich nahezu jede
sehenswürdigkeit schon irgendwie abgibt
aber wir waren schon eine menge shoppen
wir waren eine menge was essen und
deswegen freuen wir uns halt was wir
jetzt überhaupt noch machen sollen aber
wir gehen erst mal was essen als wenn
ich jetzt um 10 uhr morgens ein bier
trinken etwas vergessen ich meine dass
man einem pariser eiffelturm schublade
anbietet kann ich halt noch verstehen
eine tastatur oder eine steckdosenleiste
in gottes namen kauft sich den anhänger
dieses bild zeigt so viel man sieht dass
jeder einzelne farbe für ein
lebensabschnitt steht wild mit roten
fleck sehr kreativ wie sonstwas warum
jetzt so was kunst und hier ausgestellt
ist es blau mégane als hier vorne haben
die einfach seine kollektion an videos
dann haben die noch filme und auch seine
[Musik]
kunst bei allem respekt ich versteh ich
nicht da oben wollen wir jetzt übrigens
hingehen das ist die basilika st
super diese basilika ist war heftig und
die ist da oben sollen heftigen ausweg
kann man muss nur halt ein paar stufen
hoch laufen aber sollte jetzt kein
großes problem sein
schaut euch mal diese kirchen und was
geht ab
hey das ist ja richtig crazy
[Musik]
bevor sich jemand beschweren sollte ist
man bloß deshalb der körper ist jeder
abend und ich will damit überhaupt nicht
irgendjemandem mit einem blauen liegen
bleiben oder das wasser einfach echt
sehr schön als dass ich bin ja selber
nicht übrigens fragen warum weisen
laufen wir geben gerade die komplette
basilika hoch und es stinkt lässt sich
nachlesen
ich bin ich muss überlegen was die
kölner dom franco mein gott
also es hat sich an der wm eigentlich
würde ich sagen es hat sich gelohnt habe
für sechs euro so ein sportprogramm das
krasse die normale ausblick von der
anderen seite das schon krass wenn man
mich ja wir sind wieder raus aus der
basilika da oben ist die und wir gehen
jetzt was essen weil ja macht sinn dass
man essen geht gehört was auch sonst
außer pizza sollten wir essen einladen
haben die einfach den kölner dom ihren
platziert heißt nicht ob man das
erkennen kann was da vorne herum liegt
aber das ist eine tote ratte
ich muss gleich dass logan paul auch in
paris dass wir sind wir gerade in dieser
bekannten straße über alle blogger ihre
fotos machen mit eiffelturm und diese
leute da hinten von brauchten gerade
eine gewisse zeit um ihre bilder zu
machen
sie waren hier lockt eine halbe stunde
und ich immer so zu jule so dass dieses
aufhören konnten hey wenn wir keine
bilder macht verpisst euch ich glaube
wir dachten halt die werden franzosen
oder so auf einmal sagen hey wir haben
gehört er spricht auf deutsch könnt ihr
ein foto von uns machen
1 von paris echt lassen
diese ganzen häuser also es gibt
wirklich kein aus passen nicht
wunderschön aus der ort das ist ein haus
was ist schön weil ich schaue mir gerade
nach irgendwelchen heißen foto apps mit
dem man die bilder bearbeiten damit kann
man den po beleuchtet lol steht darüber
das brandenburger tor eigentlich wollte
meine boots zu machen und mussten
deswegen an diesem fluss fahren doch
irgendwelche die falsche adresse
eingegeben und jetzt irgendwie hier also
keine ahnung wo wir sind alle minister
hrubesch ich habe tauben hast du auch
glauben das ist keine schöne frage weil
ich dachte wer in paris und in hamburg
wir sind irgendwie noch lichtjahre von
diesem fluss entfernt wie heißt noch mal
wenn ich würde sagen wir haben uns jetzt
auf jeden fall erstmal ein paar inliner
und cruisen dahin werde es geschafft
leute sind da ist das jetzt ein paar
coole 10 von harrys die wir dann film ab
[Musik]
den bootstour weg vorbei meine damen und
herren es war sehr schön und damit endet
jetzt glaube ich auch unser aufenthalt
in paris laufen jetzt gerade hier noch
von weg lang voll krass schneiden die
bäume halt echt text also gerade ab
damit das so schön aussieht und sogar
dieser schnellstraße hier sieht man also
irgendwie paris ist wirklich eine
wunderschöne stadt muss man so sagen uns
ist keine einzige hässliche stelle
aufgefallen haus hall jetzt jude ist
sehr sehr schön dass wir auch wenn ihr
jetzt auf jeden fall über und fahren von
bahnhof und fahren dann wieder zurück
nach köln von eis und einfach so einen
boxer ab wir sind wieder in köln
angekommen meine sehr verehrten freunde
dann ist es schon dunkel draußen da
vorne ist julia dave ist mittlerweile
bei mir angekommen
ich möchte mal kurz im block übernehmen
reicht dank auf jeden fall ist gerade
gamescom zeit das heißt komplett köln
ist voll mit 400.000 gaming besuchern
gaming interessenten nicht gaming
besuchern allerdings sind deswegen auch
einige partys gerade und wir fahren
jetzt noch zu einer hin
[Musik]
ja leute das war tatsächlich das einzige
was ich auf dieser party gefilmt habe
ich bin ganz ehrlich wir waren noch
insgesamt laufe ich nur so für 20
minuten da ich bin gott hat dunkel jetzt
bin ich zu helfen wir sind jetzt auf
jeden fall wieder zu hause angekommen
hier
das geht auf jeden fall würde ich den
blog an dieser stelle jetzt auch beenden
freunde
wir waren halt wirklich dass sie gerade
sehr sehr lustig aus wie waren als heute
den ganzen tag auch in paris unterwegs
sind die komplette sacre coeur
hochgelaufen durch diese engen stufen
und das war nicht sehr anstrengend ich
hoffe euch jedoch gefallen wird etwas
getan hat das gerne ein leichter freunde
und schreibt mir doch bitte gern mal in
die kommentare was ihr auf meinem kanal
in letzter zeit so ein bisschen vermisst
sage ich mal an seißen format oder sei
es irgendein video was euch damals sehr
gefallen hat was wir gern mal wieder
sehen würdet ihr dürft also quasi
entscheiden was in den nächsten blogs
passiert was ich mal wieder machen werde
und bis dahin bleibt fresh verbreitet
frieden und nehmen keine drogen und
passen der schule auf
[Musik]